hello and welcome to the 16th
fundamental investing with use of
programming tutorial where we left off
in the last video I showed you guys how
to combine your stock screener with the
quantal data to show you the you know
various financial statistics that you
might be interested in in companies that
past your screeners variables next I
want to show you guys how to incorporate
the quantal data with the screener with
the financial charting program that I
built before as well so that is this if
you don't know it that it's the whole
playlist is that in my channel [ __ ] I
think it's pioneer charting stocks in
Python it would be this tutorial here
Python charting stocks / Forex for
technical analysis and the output of
that chart was the following when you
ran it it just asked you what's stopped
to plot so you would tell it an hour and
what we're gonna do is actually have it
to plot the stock that matches or passes
the screen but for example if we did go
through with Yahoo for example it puts
up a chart like this and so we had the
MACD the RSI the candlestick open
high/low close here and then some simple
moving averages of the data it was a
fairly nice charting application
basically built within Python in
matplotlib so now what I want to do is
incorporate the other statistics that
we've got like the financial data and
all that and also plot that in this same
figure so what I'm going to do is we're
just going to put three more bars down
here but of course you could replace the
RSI and the MACD with two of them and
add one more you could share an axis and
plot all three of them actually on the
same axis or you could do what we're
going to do so really the opportunity to
do whatever you want is here and if you
did follow through this entire tutorial
you've got definitely the tools and the
knowledge to do pretty much whatever you
want but
what I'm going to be doing is
incorporating the finance data right
into here with from quando and the
screener and that way we have a decent
long-term investing program so with that
I'm going to close out of this and let's
go ahead and get started I'm going to
close out of here as well so the first
thing I want to do is let's make the
space and make those axes and then we'll
work on gathering the data running it
through the screener so this was where
we left off basically in that in that
final tutorial in the Python charting
stocks program series so if your chart
looks like what I just showed you that's
where you are anyways so the next thing
we need to do is come down to where
we're making all these axes and we need
to specify three more axes so what I'm
going to do is eventually this will be
changed but we'll get to that in a
second so first we're going to come down
here and we're going to specify some new
axes and the easiest thing to do would
be to copy and paste a similar version
of what we plan to do so a lot of these
have structuring to them so I guess
first we'll just take this one right
here so anything that has this plot it's
up grid just copy and paste it it's got
the same data that we want so we'll come
back down and here that'll be the
beginning now we also want to copy this
data here we'll come down here there we
go paste that and obviously we need to
edit some of that stuff but actually and
then the tick parameters we want to take
that as well so come down from here
paste those tick parameters and we also
are going to want to edit those side
things as well
so now what we'll do is first of all
this would be axes three three three
three
three and hey let me actually do one
more thing to just so we can recall
where we're late
where we left off here just so we can
easily find this I'm just going to put
this here now well this was X is three
we're going to change this to it
four and now let's well this is also
going to instead of being a six by four
since we're going to add three more
columns we'll make this a nine by four
and will edit the above ones in just a
minute I'm gonna copy and paste these
parameters now two more times and then
this one instead of axis three will be X
4 and this will be axis five now what we
need to do is edit the axes other axes
so they all need to say 9 by 4 9 and we
ought to have should be the last one so
it's always good whenever you're doing
something like this kind of worried just
meshing two things together so it could
get pretty messy so you kind of 1 check
your progress as you go so let's see
where we stand now I'll bring it over
here we'll plot Yahoo again and sure
enough we have the chart looking like
this so we're going to figure out what
what went wrong there cuz we're also not
we're not drawing the axes that we
should have drawn so let's see
well initially definitely one thing I
see already and this is okay so I think
I found our our error here a couple of
things that we did wrong immediately
first of all we need to put a share X in
here this isn't what we did wrong but
share X axes one and let's go ahead and
copy and paste that through here and the
other thing that we need to do is
specify the starting points so this
really needs to start this one let's see
where is plot or X's two's definition
here it starts at five zero so this one
needs to start at six zero seven zero
eight zero subsequently it also needs to
it can span the four columns but only
needs to span one row so fix that as
well I didn't realize I'd flip these I
don't think that'll be an issue
anyway close out of this now let's rerun
it
pull up Yahoo again that looks a little
bit more what we were looking for
it's obviously we've got the dates here
that we need to get rid of and then we
want to curve or not curve angle the
dates here so let's go ahead and do that
and then I'll cut the video here and
we'll continue on the next video
actually populating the data here so
we'll close out of here and move this
side again and what we want to do now is
if you recall to get rid of that data
well the first thing we want to do the
label in acts is to no longer should be
actually it's five and then here we want
to silence forgot what kind of where I
was but we really need to silence two
three and four I should do it so let me
bring that chart up again real quick see
where we stand
cool okay so now we're decently arranged
we could go one step further and prune
away another figure here cuz as you can
see they kind of still are running into
each other but I'm
I'm gonna worry about doing that if you
guys really want to feel free just like
you just find this prune command here
you could prune the lower if you want
it's something like that staggering
maybe if you wanted anyway
mostly I'm interested in seeing the
directional huh change in these figures
anyways for the fundamental financial
data figures so you're not at too
interested in seeing the exact amount
right and if you were you know then you
would know where to draw the line and
you would have drawn that line in the
screener anyway so now that we have that
room in the next video what we're going
to be doing is populating that by
requested stock and then and then
probably not in that video in the next
video after that we'll add it to the
screener and we'll have concluded our
investing program so as always thanks
for watching thanks for your support
your subscriptions and until next time